Welcome to this tutorial
on creating forms in KoboToolbox.
Today we'll learn how to use
the KoboToolbox Formbuilder.
First, log in to your account
on the Global Server.
Once you're logged in,
click on the NEW button.
This opens the form creation dialog
where you can start a new project.
You can choose to start from scratch
or use the Question Library.
The Question Library has templates
for common data collection needs.
For this tutorial, let's start
with a blank form.
Click on "Build from scratch"
to continue.
Now you're in the Formbuilder interface
where you can add questions.
To add a question,
click the plus icon here.
You'll see different question types
you can choose from.
Let's add a text question first.
This is the most basic type.
Type your question in the
label field here.
Notice the data column name
is auto-generated.
This is important for when you
export your data later.
Now let's add a select question
for multiple choice options.
Click the plus icon again
and choose Select One.
You need to add choices
for the respondent to select.
Click on "Add choice" to add
each option one by one.
Each choice needs a label
that people will see.
And a value that will be stored
in your data column.
For location-based data,
you can use cascading selects.
This filters choices based on
previous answers.
For example, select country,
then city within that country.
To set this up, you need to create
your list_name in the choices sheet.
We'll cover cascading selects
in detail in another video.
Let's add one more important
question type.
The GPS question automatically
collects location data.
This is very useful for field surveys
in humanitarian work.
Click the plus icon and
select "geopoint" from the list.
When someone fills out your form,
this captures their coordinates.
Now that we've added some questions,
let's save our work.
Click the SAVE button
at the top right.
Your form is now saved as a Draft
in your project list.
When you're ready to use it,
you need to deploy.
Click the DEPLOY button
to make it active.
You can then collect data using
KoboCollect on Android.
Or share the web form link
for online data collection.
To view your collected data,
go to the DATA tab.
Here you can see submissions
in table or map view.
You can export your data
in various formats like Excel.
That's the basics of creating
a form in KoboToolbox!
Check out our other tutorials
for more advanced features.
Thanks for watching, and happy
data collecting!